>>> IN OUR NATIONAL LEAD, THE
SUSPECT IN THE UNIVERSITY OF
IDAHO STUDENT KILLINGS IS
SCHEDULED TO BE IN COURT
TOMORROW IN PENNSYLVANIA, WHERE
HE IS EXPECTED TO NOT FIGHT
EFFORTS TO BRING HIM BACK TO
IDAHO TO FACE FOUR MURDER
CHARGES.
TODAY CNN'S JEAN CASARES SPOKE
WITH THE PUBLIC DEFENDER
ASSIGNED TO THE CASE IN MONROE
COUNTY, PENNSYLVANIA.
>> Reporter: THE MAN WHO POLICE
SAY KILLED FOUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS, THEN WEEKS LATER DROVE
CROSS-COUNTRY TRACKED BY POLICE,
WILL GO BACK TO IDAHO TO FACE
CHARGES.
>> DETECTIVES ARRESTED
28-YEAR-OLD BRYAN CHRISTOPHER
KOHBERGER.
>> Reporter: ETHAN CHAPIN, ZANA
KERNODLE, MADISON AND KAYLEE
GONCALVES WERE STABBED IN THIS
MOSCOW, IDAHO HOME.
DNA WAS RECOVERED AT THE CRIME
SCENE.
A SOURCE WITH KNOWLEDGE OF THE
INVESTIGATION TELLS CNN THE
SUSPECT WAS IDENTIFIED THROUGH
GENETIC GENEALOGY, A PROCESS
WHERE DNA FROM AN INVESTIGATION
IS COMPARED TO A PUBLIC
DATABASE, POTENTIALLY LEADING TO
A FAMILY MEMBER OF A SUSPECT.
KOHBERGER'S LAWYER SAYS HIS
FATHER FLEW TO WASHINGTON STATE
TO BRING HIM TO NORTHEAST
PENNSYLVANIA FOR THE HOLIDAYS.
>> HIS FATHER WENT OUT THERE AND
THEY DROVE HOME TOGETHER.
>> Reporter: THEY DROVE HIS
WHITE HYUNDAI ELANTRA.
CNN CONFIRMED THEY STOPPED AT A
REPAIR SHOP IN PENNSYLVANIA
WHERE SOME WORK WAS DONE ON THE
VEHICLE.
>> I BELIEVE HE ARRIVED
SOMEWHERE AROUND THE 17th OF
DECEMBER.
>> THE CHIEF PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR
MONROE COUNTY, PENNSYLVANIA, IS
REPRESENTING KOHBERGER UNTIL HE
IS EXTRADITED.
A LAW ENFORCEMENT SOURCE SAYS
THE FBI WATCHED HIM FOR FOUR
DAYS BEFORE HE WAS ARRESTED.
>> THE FBI, LOCAL POLICE, IDAHO
STATE TROOPERS WERE AT THEIR
HOUSE AT APPROXIMATELY 3:00 A.M.
KNOCKING ON THE DOOR AND
ANNOUNCING THEMSELVES.
>> Reporter: KOHBERGER GRADUATED
IN MAY WITH A MASTERS IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND WAS
PURSUING A DOCTORATE AT
WASHINGTON STATE UNIVERSITY ONLY
ABOUT SEVEN MILES AWAY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO.
HE HAS TO APPRECIATE THE
SERIOUSNESS OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
>> ABSOLUTELY, HE IS VERY
INTELLIGENT, I CAN TELL THAT.
AND HE UNDERSTANDS WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW.
>> Reporter: WHILE IN COLLEGE AT
DeSALES, KOHBERGER ASKED EX-CONS
TO PARTICIPATE IN A STUDY.
THIS STUDY SEEKS TO UNDERSTAND
THE STORY BEHIND YOUR MOST
RECENT CRIMINAL OFFENSE, WITH
EMPHASIS ON YOUR THOUGHTS AND
FEELINGS THROUGHOUT YOUR
EXPERIENCE, HE WROTE ON AN
ONLINE MESSAGE BOARD.
>> THIS PERSON THAT HAD BEEN
GRADING MY PAPERS WAS ALLEGEDLY
THIS, LIKE, HORRIBLE MURDERER.
>> Reporter: KOHBERGER WAS
WORKING AS A TEACHING ASSISTANT
IN WASHINGTON AND ONE STUDENT
CLAIMS HIS DEMEANOR AND STRICT
GRADING CHANGED AFTER THE
MURDERS.
>> HE STARTED GRADING EVERYBODY
100s, AND NOW IT SEEMS LIKE HE
WAS PREOCCUPIED.
>> Reporter: FOR VICTIMS'
FAMILIES, THIS ARREST IS A STEP
TOWARD CLOSURE AND A CHANCE TO
SEE KOHBERGER IN COURT.
>> IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF HOPE,
THINGS ARE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
THERE WAS A LOT OF TIME OF NOT
KNOWING AND WE'RE DEFINITELY
GOING TO LOOK THIS GUY IN HIS
EYES.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THIS.
>> Reporter: AND THE EXTRADITION
PROCEEDING WILL TAKE PLACE RIGHT
HERE IN NORTHEASTERN
PENNSYLVANIA TOMORROW, 3:00
EASTERN TIME, AND AFTER THAT THE
AUTHORITIES WILL GET HIM BACK TO
IDAHO WHERE WE VERY SHORTLY
THEREAFTER WILL HAVE HIS INITIAL
APPEARANCE TO FACE THOSE FOUR
FELONY COUNTS OF FIRST-DEGREE
MURDER.
AND THE CHIEF PUBLIC DEFENDER
HERE IN NORTHEASTERN
PENNSYLVANIA DID TELL ME THAT HE
DOES BELIEVE IN IDAHO, WHICH HAS
THE DEATH PENALTY, THAT THIS
QUITE POSSIBLY COULD BE A
CAPITAL CASE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
>>> FORMER BOSTON POLICE
COMMISSIONER ED DAVIS JOINS US
NOW.
SOURCES TELL CNN THAT
AUTHORITIES USED A PUBLIC DNA
DATABASE TO FIND POTENTIAL
MATCHES BETWEEN DNA FOUND AT THE
MURDER SCENE AND THEN THE
POTENTIAL FAMILY MEMBERS AND
THAT LED TO THE SUSPECT.
HYPOTHETICALLY, HOW WOULD THAT
WORK?
HAS THAT HAPPENED BEFORE?
>> HI, JAKE.
YES, IT HAS, AND IT'S BEING USED
MORE AND MORE OFTEN.
BUT YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THIS IS
NOT A DEFINITIVE TEST.
THAT WILL GIVE YOU SOMETIMES A
NUMBER OF SUSPECTS, DOZENS,
MAYBE HUNDREDS, THAT YOU HAVE TO
START TO FILTER THROUGH, AND
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR AFTER
YOU GET THAT INITIAL LIST IS
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SOME PROXIMITY
TO THE CRIME OR SOME MOTIVATION.
IF HIS NAME POPPED AND HE WAS IN
THE AREA, HE DROVE AN ELANTRA,
THOSE ARE, OBVIOUSLY, INDICATORS
THAT WOULD HAVE TO FBI
CONCENTRATING ON HIM.
IN THE PAST WHEN WE'VE RUN INTO
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS, WE WOULD
ATTEMPT TO GET A DIRECT SAMPLE
OF DNA FROM THE SUSPECT.
SO THOSE SURVEILLANCE TEAMS MAY
HAVE BEEN DOING MORE THAN JUST
WATCHING HIM.
THEY MAY HAVE BEEN LOOKING FOR
DISCARDED WATER BOTTLES OR OTHER
THINGS THAT WOULD PRODUCE A
SAMPLE THAT THEY COULD CHECK TO
BE CERTAIN THAT IT WAS, IN FACT,
HIM.
>> NOT EVERY ONE OF THESE
GENETIC DATABASES SHARES
INFORMATION WILLINGLY WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
I USE ANCESTRY.COM.
I DON'T THINK THEY WILLINGLY
SHARE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OTHERS DO.
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> I DO, TOO, WHEN I THINK -- I
THINK THAT INFORMATION IS
ACCURATE.
IT ALL DEPENDS ON THE SYSTEM
THAT YOU'RE PUTTING YOUR DNA
INTO, WHETHER OR NOT THEY TELL
YOU THEY'RE GOING TO SHARE AND
WHETHER YOU SIGN A RELEASE.
AND IN SOME CASES, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THAT RELEASE IT MIGHT NOT
TELL YOU DIRECTLY AND THEN
YOU'RE EXPOSING YOUR -- NOT ONLY
YOURSELF, BUT YOUR FAMILY TO A
REVIEW BY PUBLIC AUTHORITIES.
>> WE LEARNED OVER THE WEEKEND
THAT THE SUSPECT AND HIS FATHER
DROVE ACROSS THE COUNTRY AFTER
THE KILLINGS, SUPPOSEDLY IN THIS
HYUNDAI ELANTRA THAT WAS
POSSIBLY SEEN AT THE SITE OF THE
CRIME SCENE.
WHAT WOULD YOU WANT TO ASK HIS
FATHER IF YOU HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO?
>> WELL, I WOULD CERTAINLY WANT
TO ASK IF THERE WERE ANY
INDICATIONS THAT HE WAS FEELING
STRESSED OR DISORIENTED OR NOT
PAYING ATTENTION TO THINGS.
ALL OF THOSE WOULD BE
INDICATORS.
HE MAY HAVE CONFESSED.
SOMETIMES PEOPLE IN THIS
SITUATION, WHEN THEY FEEL SAFE
WITH A LOVED ONE, WILL START TO
TALK ABOUT IT.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT HAPPENED IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE, BUT THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
ASK THE FATHER.
AND, ALSO, WAS THERE ANYTHING IN
THE CAR THAT MAY BE HELPFUL.
TRACE EVIDENCE IS A HUGE I